willkommen bei viel platz der ersten
sitzung unser erstes interview über das
thema beziehungsweise die philosophische
theorien über animalis muss hallo jörg
vorstandschef ich fange einfach gleich
mal mit der erste frage an kann zu
unterziehen was ist die these des
animismus und wie sehr entstand also
animalis muss ist relativ junge theorien
der philosophie des geistes könnte auch
pflegende und theologie personalie
ökologie deren these besagt dass wir
mutig wesentlich tiere das ist die
hauptthese des animismus und lisa
entstanden aber es gibt schon gewisse
vorläufe theorien artikel bei
aristoteles einmal rationale also ein
flüchtig ist hier aber ein tier dass
eben vernünftig ist gewisse vermögen
gewisse eigenschaften hat aber immer
noch ein tier und animalis muss selbst
daran an die pflege des animismus die
theorie hat sich seinen 80er jahren des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts entwickelt und
bis heute immer prominente geworden ist
natürlich auch eine strittige theorie
wieder würde sagen dass du nicht dass
wir wie schon die tiere sind wir würden
sagen dass wir personen sind ja genau
sagen die meisten es gibt hier einen
bedeutenden vertreter und er hat ein
buch geschrieben
bislang ist der titel und personal
identity wird auf zwei partitionen
psychologie personal identität mit sich
nicht an unsere busse zahlen selbst
seien zum beispiel zu einem lebendigen
körper
kannst du das beispiel und kann sich
vorstellen alle zum beispiel wenn wir
jetzt unser gehirn tauschen der also
wenn ich jetzt mein gehirn sozusagen
körper verklagt den das verpflanzt würde
dein gehirn in meinem körper
was würdest du sagen wo gehst du hin
also wenn man hier ist also dann wäre
ich als addieren könnten auch genau um
einen psychologischen bewusstsein ist wo
die ganzen erinnerungen sind wo genau
und der realismus sagt eben einem eben
nicht feiern hier sind diejenigen die
lebendigen körper haben also deine
weniger kürzer wäre derselbe öffentlich
der regel in deinem gehirn transportiert
würde
das heißt du würdest nicht wie dein
gehirn gehen sondern dein körper würde
sich ausmachen auch ohne dein gehirn
wenn er noch lebendig wäre das ist
verschließt um die natürlich ein
bisschen kontrollen positiv auf der
anderen seite hatte theorie des
animismus viele vorteile zum beispiel
würdest du sagen dass du identisch ist
mit dir als fötus kannst du dich
erinnern an deine zustand als für mich
haben mieterinnen aber ich würde schon
sagen dass plötzlich also soll ich das
warten
genauso wenig ist aber sagst dass du
eigentlich das bist du an dich erinnern
kannst dann ist es ein problem mein
kannst du dir genannten mittel total der
animierten und arrivierte stärke das
sagt es kommt nicht auf erinnerung an
auf 2,4 als erinnerungs relation sind es
kommt darauf an ob das gewählte leben
müssen habe ich das sehr wir leben mit
mir als zyklus
natürlich habe ich dasselbe aber eben
nicht auf basis von psychologie ist hat
keine erinnerung wie man sich in einer
fötus sind man weiß nur 27 körper
organismus der sich dann entwickelt hat
der gewisse fähigkeiten entwickelt hat
im lauf der zeit in seiner person
gemacht verstehen gibt es noch weitere
probleme
ja also zb dann
die animalis muss nicht so viel darüber
aus was ist eine person muss
personalität interessierte minimalismus
ist die nur um körper genau es geht um
menschliche tiere und personalität ist
eine eigenschaft zustand den tipp dass
menschen die hier im lauf der zeit
erwerben kann sich ein vermögen werden
aktualisiert vernunft zum beispiel aber
eben nur phasenweise eben nicht als wir
waren wirklich alle versuchen und wenn
wir mal vielleicht menschen oder kein
bewusst vergaben dann sind wir auch
nicht mehr richtig personal steht und
damit ein bisschen problem weil wir
teilweise dazu tendieren durchsagen wir
sind immer in person gewesen oder so ein
großes update also gibt es alle
möglichen motiven darüber noch ein paar
mehr bücher dabei zitierte buch zum
beispiel danach ist von linker
alternativ theorie zum thema animalis
muss und zwar mit limberg an ihrem buch
eine sogenannte konstitution story
konstitution zur heißt wir sind nicht
identisch und uns um lippen gegen körper
zum der körper konstituiert uns als das
identische gene einheit ein
aber sie nicht dasselbe und das hat uns
zur person machte es unser selbst
fußball und wieder lebendiger körper das
ist eine gegenposition zu dieser these
sich an malliß muss gibt noch andere ich
habe noch ein buch von der biologischen
perspektive betrachtet geht als auch per
winde konstitution theorie getan haben
wir eine erste person perspektive wie es
sie so ihre person perspektive zu
verstehen ich konnte sich an genau auch
die was man die qualität hat das da ist
noch der bereits technologisch als die
ökologisch orientierte konstitution
story also da gibt es keine
ok danke für diesen für den abschluss
nicht infrage
damit werden wir am ende angelangt
vielen dank ich hoffe ihr konto das
lernen